though the one thing I'm doing when
inspiration hits is I'm sitting in my
studio playing guitar or playing
keyboards or sitting in front of the
computer but as long as I'm there that
way I can capture and I can document it
and it it becomes sort of almost like an
ascetic monastic location you know like
it's just me alone in my small studio
which is sort of like a monastic cell
and I at some point I mean you know that
they'll do document you know
documentaries on musicians like a behind
the music on the dramatic things that
are involved in making a record and for
me would be the most tedious documentary
in the world because it's just me
sitting in a chair in front of a
computer or in front of a keyboard and
there's really not a lot going on